bonsoir j'ai un projet a proposé à
l'humanité un grand projet humanistes et
universelles pour l'humanité toute
entière et par l'humanité tout entière
un projet porteur d'un espoir fou d'une
belle utopie un projet pour les siècles
à venir jusqu'à la fin des temps humain
un projet pour l'éternité
c'est sûr que dit comme ça je me mets à
votre place je me dirais lui soit il à
moitié ravagé soit il a pris des
substances illicites avant de venir et
c'est pas du tout le cas je peux même
vous dire un truc
ce qui me frappe le plus dans le monde
que nous vivons c'est que justement on
le voit toujours pas apparaître le grand
projet humaniste de notre époque
le projet qui utiliserait les
technologies d'aujourd'hui notamment les
technologies du numérique à des fins
humaniste pour replacer l'être humain au
centre de tout pour le sacraliser pour
le sanctuary zay
ce qui est étrange c'est que la
révolution du numérique est une
révolution au moins aussi déterminante
que celle de l'imprimerie et de
guttenberg
mais alors que l'imprimerie a été
clairement à l'origine de l'essor de la
renaissance de l'humanisme et du siècle
des lumières on ne voit toujours pas en
quoi internet et le numérique ont
apporté un courant de pensée qui puisse
s'apparenter de près ou de loin à une
forme d'humanisme de notre époque
vous allez me dire on s'en fout on à
google en instructeurs en à facebook on
allait nbc on a le big data on a les
objets connectés
on a tout cette espèce de logorrhée
technologie qui a remplacé la pensée oui
mais on n'a toujours pas un grand projet
porteur de sens pour chacun d'entre nous
et qui nous inscrirait dans un destin
commun en réalité le nouveau monde du
numérique il est dirigé par une poignée
d'individus dans la silicon valley qu'on
appelle les gars faim et qui eux sont
plus de tradition libertaire
qu'humaniste et en guise d'humanisme eux
ils nous proposent le transhumanisme
vous savez le transhumanisme l'homme
augmenté la mort de la mort le cerveau
qu'on va pouvoir brancher sur internet
qui va devenir un gros moteur
d'intelligence artificielle a conscience
qu'on va pouvoir transférer sur des
puces de silicium l'adn qu'on va pouvoir
bidouiller comme on veut pour devenir
plus grand plus beau plus forts plus
intelligents plus heureux on nous
présente tout ça comme une sorte d'app
en âge de la modernité une sorte de
planche de salut pour l'humanité
moi ça me fait plutôt penser vous savez
au aux alchimistes du moyen-âge voyez
c'est un petit peu comme si la graine
des les bords ou la bave de crapaud
avait été remplacé par les ntic
mais en réalité c'est exactement le même
obscurantisme le même délire les mêmes
barjots alors nous face à saint nous là
ce soir nous les petits français
nous les citoyens du pays des droits de
l'homme du pays des lumières de la
pensée humaniste nous les anciens
révolutionnaires on fait quoi on est
devenu des espèces de petits bourgeois
dépressif un coup cynique un coup
sceptique on avale tout ça sans broncher
on est devenu absolument incapable
d'allumer le moindre contre-feu 1
capable d'éclairer le monde
d'aujourd'hui le monde numérique de nos
traditions de penser à nous de notre
éducation républicaine de notre
éducation humaniste
on est devenus passif est dépassé on a
déjà renoncé
le projet dont je veux vous parler
aujourd'hui il est issu de la
constatation suivante le numérique
l'information numérique c'est la chose
la plus pérenne que l'homme ait jamais
engendré dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité on n'a jamais engendré une
chose aussi pérenne en effet une
information numérique pour peu qu'il
existe toujours un être humain qui
acceptent de la transférer de support en
support au fur et à mesure de
l'obsolescence de ces supports et bien
cette information numérique
elle a une longévité infinie elle a un
caractère potentiel d'éternité alors je
ne parle évidemment pas de l'éternité à
l'échelle de l'univers spirituel ou
matériels qui sont évidemment hors
d'atteinte
mais de l'éternité à l'échelle de la
civilisation humaine en tant que
civilisation structure est une donnée
numérique si on le décide vraiment on
pourrait décider de la conserver jusqu'à
la fin des temps humain ça n'est jamais
arrivé dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité
alors si maintenant cette donnée
numérique elle est relative justement à
un être humain vous son d'une voix
la photo d'un visage le roman d'une vie
bien si on le voulait vraiment pourrait
décider de conserver la mémoire
numérique de cet être humain jusqu'à la
fin des temps humain plus encore on
pourrait le proposer pour la totalité
des êtres humains
en effet la matérialité du numérique
c'est à dire la quantité de ressources
consommées et le volume de ces supports
est devenu négligeable par rapport à la
quantité d'informations que ces supports
sont capables de stocker voyez par
exemple la photo d'un visage sur un
disque dur ça peu près la taille d'une
poussière et tout ce qu'on peut raconter
dans sa vie babillage de bébés compris
ça tient sur ce même disque dur
aujourd'hui si on voulait vraiment si
c'était un projet de l'humanité on
pourrait décider de conserver la mémoire
de tous les êtres humains jusqu'à la fin
des temps humain bon c'est pas parce
qu'une chose est devenu possible qu'elle
est souhaitable
donc essayons de raisonner avec notre
éducation et nos traditions de pensée
humaniste
quand on est un humaniste on essaie de
réfléchir à la valeur de la vie et pour
un humaniste la valeur d'une vie humaine
c'est inestimable ça une valeur il
steam abl une vie c'est une une
combinaison génétique absolument
impossible à reproduire suivi d'une
succession d'émotion de rencontres
d'expérience elle même impossible à
reproduire une vie c'est plus rare que
le plus rares des métaux rares et ses
plus précieux que la plus précieuse des
oeuvres d'art est donc à ce titre la
mémoire d'une vie humaine en tant que
manifestation tangible d'une existence
on devrait pouvoir l'inscrire au
patrimoine immatériel de l'humanité
et puisque nous on est du pays des
droits de l'homme on pourrait même
imaginer un nouveau droit de l'homme le
droit à la mémoire et la postérité pour
tous du style tous les êtres humains
naissent vivent et meurent égaux dans le
droit à la postérité et une mémoire
volontaire de leur vie devra pouvoir
être conservées jusqu'à la fin des temps
humain indépendamment de toute
considération de race de religion
d'origines de cultures de ressources et
même de renommée similairement le droit
à l'oubli est un droit fondamental qui
doit pouvoir être exercées
si telle est la volonté de la personne
alors c'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui
depuis la nuit des temps on accepter
tous tacitement qu'il y ait une
hiérarchie entre les vies humaines en
regard de la postérité
si vous prenez par exemple les êtres
humains du xxème siècle qui passeront la
barrière de la postérité à milan à coup
sûr y aura hitler et staline mais
pratiquement personne parmi les millions
de gens qui sont morts dans les goulags
ou dans les camps et puis cette idée
sournoise et nauséabonde
selon laquelle il y aurait une
hiérarchie entre la valeur des vies elle
continue de ramper aujourd'hui il suffit
de regarder nos sdf qui sont devenus les
ombres de nauru à qui on ne donne
pratiquement plus le statut d'être
humain où les migrants qui meurent sur
les plages ou les kamikazes sacrifier
alors tant qu'on avait la libye de la
limitation technologie qui rendait
impossible la conservation de la mémoire
de tous les hommes
on pouvait accepter comme tri s'opère
mais aujourd'hui que c'est devenu
possible
comment continuer à trier et selon quels
critères
quels seront les vies qui valent le coup
d'être conservé celle qui ne valent pas
le coup imaginez que ça existe
imaginez déjà que depuis une centaine
d'années ce droit la mémoire la
postérité pour tous soit un droit à
exercer dans le monde et que la mémoire
de tous les hommes soit inscrite au
patrimoine immatériel de l'humanité
beaucoup de choses serait modifié le
rapport à la généalogie serait modifiée
puisque on pourra les lire écouter voir
ce que nos ancêtres ont voulu nous
transmettre le rapport à l'histoire
serait complètement transformé puisque
ce serait un droit de chaque être humain
que d'écrire une partie de l'histoire
humaine
et puis petit à l'école on dirait voilà
un de nos biens communs les plus
précieux c'est la mémoire de tous les
hommes
on essaye de se transmettre de
génération en génération
et toi aussi tu as toute ta vie pour
réfléchir à ce que tu veux transmettre à
qui tu voudras le transmettre comment tu
voudras le transmettre mais ce que tu
décideras de donner au reste de
l'humanité pour la communauté des hommes
ça aura une valeur inestimable
on imagine bien que ce serait
incontestablement un nouvel élément de
sens
une pierre a ajouté la construction de
nos vies et puis ce serait aussi une
façon d'entériner à jamais une forme
d'altruisme dans la mémoire qu'on donne
à ceux qui nous succèdent ce serait
exactement à l'opposé de cette espèce de
quête vaine et narcissique de
l'immortalité promise par les
transhumanistes pour porter un projet
comme ça évidemment il faut imaginer une
organisation mondiale à caractère
philanthropique dans un cadre éthique
précis à but non lucratif avec une
gouvernance démocratique soumises à un
contrôle citoyen on ne peut pas
continuer comme on le fait aujourd'hui a
confié nos mémoires sur des serveurs en
californie qui appartiennent à des
boîtes commercial on ne peut pas
continuer d'accepter que la mémoire de
tous les hommes est un bien marchand
pour porter ce projet nous avons créé
une association qui s'appelle les
ternésiens qui est synonyme de mémoire
éternelle son logo est là mais négatives
dans la grotte du paléolithique et un
symbole universel du besoin de traces de
l'être humain notre objectif est
d'interpeller les leaders d'opinion les
politiques
les grandes organisations les
gouvernements l'onu l'unesco les
responsables des grandes religions pour
que cette question du droit à la mémoire
la postérité
pour tous et de l'inscription de la
mémoire de tous les êtres humains au
patrimoine de l'humanité soient soumises
à débat citoyen ça soit soumis à la
controverse qu'on en parle et qu'on
redevienne acteurs de ce nouveau monde
du numérique
cette association est ouverte à tous
ceux qui comme moi pensent que la
question de la transmission et de la
mémoire sera au coeur de l'un des grands
projet humaniste du 21e siècle
vous avez compris que la technologie net
ici comme prétexte qu'un moyen pour
arriver un but si comme dans la légende
du roi midas il existait des robes des
roseaux pour raconter l'histoire des
vies sous l'effet de la brise je vous
proposerai de planter des roseaux
partout dans le monde
ce que je sais c'est que ça va arriver
je sais qu'un jour la communauté des
hommes décidera de conserver la mémoire
de tous les humains
je le sais depuis toujours je le sais
depuis je suis enfant je le sais parce
que je sais qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
avenir pour l'humanité que de considérer
que chacune de nos vies est une oeuvre
d'art et que chacun de nous est sacrée
merci